je pense qu'on peut aussi regretter
collectivement que le sujet de la
rentrée ce soit cette question de la
Baya qui occulte un peu tous les autres
sujets et notamment des sujets très
importants comme le manque de professeur
comme la place du professeur comme le
rôle que nous voulons confier ensemble
collectivement au professeur et à
l'école dans notre société c'est le
professeur c'est la clé de voûte de
notre école la question c'est
aujourd'hui quelle mission on peut lui
confier comment est-ce que on peut
utiliser la relation que le professeur a
avec les élèves pour résoudre un certain
nombre de difficultés de notre de notre
société et notamment les défis éducatifs
sans précédents qui auquel on est
confronté je pense à la violence à
l'école je pense à la à l'éclatement des
cadres familiaux je pense aux additions
liées aux écrans tous ces sujets là qui
sont des vrais problèmes sur le terrain
pour les professeurs et bien on a le
sentiment qu'ils sont un peu mis de côté
et donc la question se pose de savoir si
le fait de proscrire la Baya dans le
cadre scolaire était la seule le seul
moyen
euh de de répondre à ces injonctions là
ou plutôt de grossir la barrière dans le
seul cadre scolaire est-ce qu'il y a pas
d'autres leviers qui permettraient aussi
de protéger les professeurs de ces
injonctions politiques qui pèsent sur
eux et qui les détournent je pense de
leur vraie mission d'accord j'entends ce
que vous dites mais est-ce que ça ne va
pas malgré tout dans le bon sens c'est
vrai que c'est les signalement remonter
les signalements même explosé en 2023
selon les statistiques sur ces
enseignants sur ces personnels de
direction et bien qu'il faut remonter
cette cette vague d'attente à la laïcité
est-ce que on peut pas considérer que
Gabriel Attal a une bonne fois pour
toute tranché sur le sujet et que ça va
malgré tout dans le bon sens ça va tout
à fait dans le bon sens la vraie
question c'est
quelle sera la prochaine étape parce que
c'est une offensive islamiste qui est
qui est menée contre l'école est-ce que
proscrire la Baya va régler cette
offensive en tout cas sur la question du
vêtement ça n'est pas certain puisque
aujourd'hui c'est la Baya demain ce sera
peut-être je ne sais pas les vêtements
amples ce sera d'autres moyens qui eux
que que
ils seront trouvés pour disting les gens
selon leur religion et donc peut-être
que
des outils comme l'uniforme ou d'autres
sujets qui permettraient au contraire de
de mettre une bonne fois pour toute un
point final à ces revendications là
est-ce que le débat justement ne porte
pas ne devrait pas porter sur notre
capacité à délimiter ce qui est
justement de l'ordre de religieux et de
ce qui ne l'est pas je suis pas sûr que
ce soit le rôle de l'école de délimiter
ce qui est de l'ordre religieux et de ce
qui ne l'est pas
la question en revanche c'est de se
demander quel est encore une fois le
rôle que l'école doit jouer vis-à-vis de
nos élèves et comment est-ce que on peut
à la fois empêcher ces offensives de de
menacer l'équilibre des écoles et en
même temps protéger les professeurs de
ces injonctions qui pèsent sur eux parce
que là en interdisant là de manière mais
uniquement à l'école on met encore une
fois les professeurs en première ligne
de ces de ces combats là alors qu'en que
à mon sens ils ont d'autres combats à
mener pour le pour l'éducation
pour l'instruction bien sûr et c'est
combat là et bien on en parle pas
comment s'être en cette rentrée
malheureusement et face à ce débat une
question revient sur le devant de la
scène vous l'avez évoqué c'est cette
question de l'uniforme est-ce que c'est
la solution vous vous avez fait le choix
dans dans les écoles excellence ruralité
et bien d'imposer l'uniforme aux élèves
pourquoi d'abord est-ce que vous avez
fait ce choix parce que d'abord
l'uniforme c'est un outil pédagogique
formidable premièrement ça met tout le
monde sur un pied d'égalité et ça permet
aux uns et aux autres d'être membre de
la même équipe vous l'avez dit dans nos
écoles nous essayons de raccrocher ou
d'accrocher les enfants à l'école les
enfants qui sont en risque de décrochage
scolaire et l'appartenance à une école
est un levier très puissant pour
favoriser cette accrochage scolaire
parce que quand vous êtes dans une école
dans laquelle vous vous sentez bien et
bien peut-être vous auriez pu décrocher
dans un autre cadre mais là parce que
vous avez une place parce que vous êtes
attaché à un cadre parce que vous avez
un rôle à jouer et bien cet appartenance
à l'école qui est soutenu sous tendu par
l'uniforme elle vous elle va vous
peut-être être le dernier le dernier
dernier moyen de vous accrocher au cadre
scolaire donc c'est un premier levier
qui est très important le deuxième c'est
que d'un point de vue pédagogique cela
permet de matérialiser la priorité de
l'être sur la voie ça permet de montrer
que ce qu'on demande aux jeunes c'est de
se différencier non pas parce que ce
qu'il porte ce qu'ils ont mais parce
qu'ils sont et donc ils doivent se
différencier parce qu'ils ont à
l'intérieur et pas parce qu'ils revêt ça
c'est très important pédagogiquement et
puis une un élément que j'aurais dû
citer en premier c'est d'abord le fait
que ça met tout le monde sur un pied
d'égalité donc ça limite aussi tous les
phénomènes de harcèlement ça c'est très
important
l'uniforme apaise beaucoup de choses
parce que tout le monde est habillé
pareil comme dans une équipe de foot
qu'en pensent les élèves est-ce que vous
sentez vous qu'il expérimenté depuis
plusieurs années et bien que c'est
quelque chose qui est rentré dans leurs
habitudes et que c'est quelque chose
finalement qu'ils apprécient ah tout à
fait moi honnêtement on l'avait jamais
mis en oeuvre dans ce dans le dans
lequel on l'a mis c'est à dire dans des
zones rurales défavorisées quand on
s'est installé là-bas je ne savais pas
dans quel mesure ce serait plus ou moins
accepté localement ça a été très
facilement vraiment on a eu aucun
problème à faire accepter l'uniforme et
aujourd'hui les élèves ils sont très
attachés il y a de très belles histoires
avec l'uniforme parce qu'en fait il y a
une vraie pédagogie autour de l'uniforme
on remet solennellement l'uniforme à un
élève à un mois après son entrée à
l'école et il décide au moment de
recevoir cet uniforme de porter haut les
valeurs de l'école dans le cadre de
partout il portera l'uniforme donc c'est
c'est c'est très responsabilisant
l'uniforme dans le sur l'uniforme par
exemple vous avez aussi un pin's qui est
accroché et qui symbolise le rôle des
chefs d'équipe puisque la vie de l'école
est structurée autour de l'équipe
d'élèves et donc ça donne aussi un
[Musique]
les sondages montrent qu'une majorité
grandissante de français plébiscite
effectivement le retour de cet uniforme
à l'école et pourtant il reste également
assez mal vu mal compris peut-être
parfois caricaturé comme quelque chose
d'un peu vieillot comment est-ce que
vous l'expliquez
j'avoue que c'est quelque chose qui me
qui me dépasse un peu parce que je pense
que c'est vraiment un outil pour tous
les raisons que j'ai évoqué qui est
fondamental et donc
le retour qu'on a des élèves c'est pas
du tout quelque chose de vieillot pour
eux c'est une évidence que dans une
équipe de foot tout le monde a le même
maillot donc il y a pas de raison que
dans l'école on n'est pas aussi le même
maillot donc je pense que c'est quelque
chose d'assez vieillot de considérer sa
vie au bruit est-ce que vous diriez que
ça joue également sur le sentiment
d'appartenance des élèves vis-à-vis de
leur école tout à fait je pense que
c'est c'est un des éléments premiers de
de l'année de l'intérêt de l'uniforme
c'est que ça crée un collectif autour de
l'école et donc ça ça
détourne un certain nombre de de de
tentation et je vous parlais du
décrochage scolaire le fait d'appartenir
à une communauté éducative vivante et
c'est tout ça de nos écoles ça participe
vraiment à l'accrochage des jeunes et
c'est pour ça qu'on a aujourd'hui nous
sur les anciens élèves de nos
établissements il y a que 90% des élèves
qui enfin 90% des gens aujourd'hui sont
insérés en formation ou en emploi ce qui
est un ce qui est trois fois mieux que
dans le territoire vous avez 35 % de
décrochage scolaire donc ce facteur
uniforme je suis convaincu qui joue
énormément dans les résultats
d'accrochage scolaire qu'on arrive à
obtenir dans ces établissements je vous
donne un argument contre le l'uniforme à
l'école c'est d'ailleurs l'un des
principaux arguments de des opposants à
l'uniforme à l'école qui disent et bien
que cela entraverait la liberté des
élèves et les empêcherait d'exprimer
leur personnalité parce que finalement
il serait un petit peu chacun des tous
un peu des clones un peu tous pareils
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez moi je
pense que on exprime pas sa
personnalité par ses vêtements ou en
tout cas on pourra le faire par la suite
mais qu'il est d'abord primordial
notamment à
de l'adolescence d'apprendre à nos
jeunes à se différencier d'abord parce
que ce qu'ils sont au fond d'eux et pas
forcément parce que ce qu'il porte donc
c'est vraiment pour favoriser cette
expression de leur singularité mais leur
singularité profonde de ne pas de
simplement mettre des vêtements de
marque parce que c'est la mode et de
vraiment de leur singularité profonde
qu'on va leur demander justement de
pouvoir avoir le même uniforme et ce du
coup se distinguer parce qu'ils ont au
fond d'eux ce que disent également les
chefs d'établissements les professeurs
que l'on peut interroger ici ou là c'est
que au-delà de cette question de
l'uniforme pour lutter contre
l'islamisme et contre soit religieux il
faut davantage de mixer social dans les
établissements scolaires est-ce que et
bien effectivement une partie du
problème ne réside pas dans cette
question sans doute
pour ma part dans les établissements les
établissements dans lequel on est on est
situé il y a une très grande unité
scolaire voire même
une très grande orientation vers les
enfants de milieu défavorisés et c'est
l'objectif je pense que la mixité
scolaire est un moyen si vous voulez je
pense que ça n'est pas une fin en soi je
pense que il y a d'autres moyens de
permettre la réussite de de chaque
enfant la mixité scolaire c'est un peu
une manière de sous-traiter aux élèves
de milieu favorisés la réussite des
élèves de milieu défavorisés je crois
que c'est un levier qui est intéressant
mais tout d'abord ce qui fait la
réussite d'un jeune ça va être la
relation qui va tisser avec le
professeur cette relation qui va lui
redonner confiance en lui cette relation
qui va lui montrer que il a un intérêt
indépendamment de son de son de ses
résultats scolaires et tout ça ça passe
par une vision du professeur qui est à
mon sens à repenser aujourd'hui et qui
fait peut-être un peu défaut dans les
interventions qu'on a pu entendre ça et
là de l'exécutif en cette rentrée
l'enjeu à mon sens c'est de permettre
aux professeur d'avoir les moyens de
passer du temps avec leurs élèves du
temps gratuit du temps où ils vont
apprendre à les connaître du point du
temps où ils vont apprendre ce qui se
passe dans leur milieu et dans leur
famille savoir aussi quels sont leurs
difficultés peut-être sociales ou
ou relationnel tout ça ça va être très
important pour donner confiance aux
jeunes dans les adultes confiance dans
le professeur et du coup bâtir ensuite
des relations de travail plus plus
fécondes et puis ça va aussi permettre
aux professeurs de jouer un vrai rôle
d'éducateur aujourd'hui les défis qui
sont devant nous toutes les défis lié
aux addictions à la violence
font que on ne peut plus se reposer sur
autrefois il y avait la paroisse il y
avait le cadre il y avait le le
village vous aviez le le la communauté
ouvrière qui transmettait des règles de
société aujourd'hui la famille et
l'école sont seules et donc elles
doivent se serrer les coudes et se
professeur éducateur il va avoir aussi
le temps en tout cas il va avoir pour
objectif de tisser une relation étroite
avec les parents au service des élèves
toute cette vision du métier du
professeur aujourd'hui je crois qu'elle
est il est essentiel de la redéfinir
pour nous mettre à jour je dirais par
rapport au défi de notre temps on ne
peut plus considérer le professeur
uniquement comme un transmetteur de
savoir on peut vous déplorer que ce ne
soit ce ne soit plus le cas mais
aujourd'hui le savoir ne fait plus
autorité si on veut qu'un professeur
soit écouté respecter et bien il doit le
baser sur la relation et d'ailleurs ce
cette légitimation de l'autorité par la
relation c'est elle est en vigueur
partout pourquoi ce ne serait pas le cas
aussi à l'école elle est en vigueur en
entreprise elle est en vigueur sans
doute dans votre métier dans le mien
c'est par la compétence démontrée et la
relation que on est aujourd'hui crédible
et bien c'est ce vers quoi il faut qu'on
tende pour revoir et changer le rôle du
professeur sachant que tout ce que vous
dites là ne passe pas uniquement par la
question de l'uniforme non bien sûr que
non ça passe justement par une vision
plus large qui est une manière de
repenser ce qu'on va demander aux
professeur et donc le suivi qui va le
faire de chaque enfant et donc le nombre
d'élèves qui va avoir en face de lui et
donc la relation qui va tisser avec les
parents tout ce travail là il est à il
est à faire et donc on ne peut pas se
satisfaire à mon sens d'une rentrée
scolaire qui je parle que d'abaya parce
qu'en réalité on passe à côté réellement
des défis de notre école justement par
si on se focalise uniquement sur sur
l'uniforme est-ce qu'on risque pas de
passer à côté du problème de fond qui
qui résulte finalement dans cette
question de l'appartenance à la
communauté nationale sans doute sans
doute mais s'agissant d'une rentrée
scolaire il me semble que l'enjeu il est
il est il est non seulement de de penser
bien sûr à créer du commun par l'école
mais au-delà de se demander par exemple
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a plus que on a 13
% de poste non pourvu au concours de
l'éducation nationale quelle est la
crise de sens qu'il y a dans le métier
de professeur qui fait que aujourd'hui
on n'arrive pas à recruter qu'on a 14
heures en moyenne par professeur 12
millions d'heures sur l'année de
professeur non remplacé donc ce cette
crise là il faut la prendre à abracor et
c'est vraiment tout l'enjeu de notre
rentrée je pense merci beaucoup
Jean-Baptiste